oh 16 years old Wellington New
Zealand thinking about they go play
basketball and at school Kristen was her
name that's the problem with Irish
alcohol memories memories come flatting
back and you do stupid things you do
stupid things reminds you
of where's
[Music]
Kristen hey everybody what you doing I
don't care I'm tier I'm Michael yay so
you are watching snack Wars and it's the
New Zealand versus Ireland Edition on
blad Bible boom
oh there we go he there Stone right it's
a winner it's a winner Che this is a
classic New Zealand
beer listen no off you
don't is it that bad can we get a couple
of glasses yeah is your
want gu your Drinker Choice Marco when
I'm at home yeah don't drink it really
abroad doesn't travel very well
unfortunately is that is that we're just
having this conversation today he he's
looking at he like this guy like can't
wait to get out of here so that's the
real thing then Guinness is better in
Island it is and you know people don't
believe it until they go there and then
they're like oh yeah you weren't just
saying that very well done on the pool
there by the way not bad not bad well I
mean you can't get it wrong with a can
they're not bad actually the can's
better cheers
well are you going to at least give Tu a
chance to respond no
point we all know
that listen I'll help them out I'll
throw him a bone and I say hey buy some
tat if you
want it's a funny little
bird sure we can't get you to have one
sip
of I me
happy making our sponsors at to yeah we
promise like we don't owe them
anything I mean not bad as L as far you
know for lger but no competition
yeah still going Guinness oh
yeah it's great that's a good Summer's
Day barbecue beer this is a good rainy
October writing a poem
yeah uh lamenting everything that ever
happened to you in your life and last
relationship I forgot about that I saw
it on your own totally forgot loran feed
Mona honey wine llorian if you really
want to get somebody in the move open so
this
aure sort of sweet wine sort of deal
exactly so you know what a f or fola is
it's a type of tree fruit I I'm I'm
guessing originally from South America
but they grow like wildfire in New
Zealand and they're
delicious alcohol may cause health
problems tell me about it um I don't
even know what Bailey's is made from
cream children the cream of the
river children's
dreams this label's not helping me
either Irish children's dreams at an
early age bottled bottled at the
source tears of
children there's definitely a goat in
here tears of kids baby goats goats
tears I love I love Bailey's but I
haven't drunk it which one should we go
for first I mean cuz the pallet is going
to be going to complet milk just try
this F
Che
Jesus hey oh that's like socks that's
like if somebody had like socks and they
went through like a a swamp and then
just like bring them ter listen it's
terrible I don't they make a great these
these guys loran they make a fantastic
sparkling version of this on the hide it
behind the B right now cuz that's a bit
too sweet okay toot sweet to
Sweet oh 16 years old Wellington New
Zealand thinking about thinking about
girl here they go played basketball
school she a bit of a tboy but
I Kristen was her
name just let's bringing back memories I
wonder what she's doing
now I've got to find
out that's the problem with Irish
alcohol youor memories come flooding
back and you do stupid things you do
stupid things reminds you of
things
where
um Bailey's got to win there Bailey's
got to win for
sure now here's what you gone wrong have
you got another piece of toast there I'm
going to show you guys once and for all
how to use Marmot that is where the
world goes wrong too much on it it's too
much need obious there's no Marmite
lovers in the
room and the toast needs to be hot
obviously it's not so I'll just make do
like
this okay guys listen here we
go okay
that much know why you need a giant tub
you don't need that that would last 3
years this much okay and then you just
do
this okay and that is plenty just like
that okay it's very strong it's an
aromatic yeast spread
and the doctor told
and and a little goes a very very long
way
okay fantastic mhm this is Bal Malo uh
original relish I always thought that it
needs to go on something delicious with
cheese sandwiches cold meats and burgers
so there no point on there does it say
delicious on a dried piece of cev bread
so I think it's a bit of a tricky one
here we can't really
um compare
them yeah it's sweet it's like a pickle
it's um it's a relish it's good isn't it
it really is good but I think it's as an
accompaniment I don't think it's in the
same category as this but I appreciate
what you're doing um cuz we don't have
uh something to to replicate the Marmite
you don't have yeast we don't have yeast
issues
um I I've never been a great Marmite fan
but I do appreciate the Marmite it's
very unique in its flavor and uh code
for it's a very special thing I mean I'm
not sure that I would have to go with
the Marmite just because of its impact
on the world so we saying M I'm saying M
gets the point oh sorry close
eyes
okay you can open now I can open oh wine
gums no Shores Shores clove Rock Shores
don't like these at all these are
fantastic these already win yeah
pineapple lumps zero pineapple in them
and more cubes than lump but I'm going
to give you one because these are this
is definitely don't like this okay
there's also good Frozen Frozen smells
good smells good very Chewy be careful
Che eat the whole thing it's
a have a go yeah have a
go have two of
them had you had those pineapple luns
before Oh no first time mhm you're
supposed to suck I think it's more of a
yeah more of a
sucker sucker and see um it's um yeah
requireed taste medicine I love this
side note in the ingredients may have an
adverse effect on attention and activity
in children
oh poison
Wars so I'm going to say that pineapple
lumps get the point there pineapples all
naturally
ingredients yeah it finished the draw oh
wow good
show
marvous look at that jawline of
[Laughter]
mine incredible you've got
[Music]
a do it do it do it I need to feel
something everyone shut up and listen
hey I'm tier I'm Michael together with
tyel and you are about to watch New
Zealand New Zealand versus Ireland snack
Wars edition no
wait hang on a minute hang on wait a
minute stop this is all usable no you
have to let it sit for I think it was
140 something seconds I think it is in
the interest of the shoe I think we
might have to not wait the 140 seconds
but well in the interest of me being
Irish we
have we have to wait that's a very
English outlook on things let the guy
settle